eric i'm gonna tweet
and we
are live with two
of my very good friends
my friend dr eric weinstein
my friend dr elise smullin how are you
wonderful gentlemen
today from california and from canada
lee how are you doing today
i'm great and you have to we have to
mention that eric and i
are old friends you guys are old friends
you're you're you're
you're old friends but you're not that
old uh you're both
uh you're both long time influences on
me eric how are you doing today
newly shorn haircut i love it
uh-oh now i can't hear you eric i heard
you a second ago
well let's see here eric can you tap the
mic again please
i hear lee but i don't hear eric
this happens surprisingly often let's
see here
eric can you hear us
not yet let's see here voice
yes yes
yes it's a little echoey it's a little
uh soft but yeah if you speak up i can
hear you
okay i can try other microphones no
that's fine
that's the that's a hanukkah present
some cosmologist got you is it not
if you're hearing me tapping than it is
yes it is
very good well today uh gentlemen we are
going to have a nice clean fight no
we're not going to have a fight we're
going to have a discussion
about a uh a series of
events that have been occurring lately
which are these theories of everything
there seems to be a proliferation
of theories of everything which come
with monikers like
the god equation the mind of god and and
all sorts of other
identities and i wanted to really just
take a step back
we had a conversation last summer with
pbs space time studios about theories of
everything
i want to take stock where we at now
with some recent events
that have come up that some say uh give
us reason to cleave to one theory
or another and these are events that are
anomalies that are unexpected that bring
up problems perhaps cracks in the
standard model
of physics and these are the lhc
uh beauty experiment and the g minus two
experiment at fermilab
and it's funny because uh as was said of
stephen hawking
he was the safest person to ever make a
bet with because no matter what side you
took you'd always win the bet
um so all the sides of these different
theories of everything seem to claim
credit post facto i want to ask you
first uh
first lee i had on michio kaku on the
into the impossible podcast
he said that these new anomalies are
totally consistent and in fact maybe
evidence for the god equation aka string
theory
um do you think that such things can
eric no laughing
uh do you think that such things could
even count as evidence for string theory
we don't even have a score card we don't
have a rubric
for what counts as you know an a plus on
a scorecard of a theory of everything
how can we say that it's evidence for
string theory if we don't even know what
it predicts
i was confused for years about what the
rubric was there was this thing about
crossing it
and then that anyway the rubicon
um look with the g minus two of the muon
let's can we get real
for a minute and i eric you can
back me up on this or not um
the g minus two is
the correction to the
magnetic moment of muon
coming from a load of different physics
some of it comes from quantum
corrections in quantum electrodynamics
itself
some of it comes from the weak and
strong interactions
give making contributions to
small quantum corrections but that's
what this is about
um there are different groups of
theorists and collaborations of
theorists
who have who have worked on
what is the actual standard model
prediction and i think it's important to
say that there's not
agreement among the theorists about what
the standard model prediction
is and i don't know enough
to have a view as to which group is
right but they
we seen both legitimate
collaborations with collaborations of
scientists so
to start with there's not one prediction
there are two predictions
and this experimental result agrees with
one of those predictions and disagrees
with another one of those predictions so
what we have
depending on what is the right
theoretical prediction
either an agreement or a disagreement
with the standard model
now it's much more fun if it's a
disagreement
but if it's a disagreement what is
the nature of it it's not profound
it's something to this if i remember i
said eighth of the ninth decimal place
of some
imagine um it
could be explained by some additional
elementary particles added to the
standard model
and i haven't thought about it but my
guess is that there's a number of
different ways you can accomplish that
because
you're trying to push a debt a high
number and a
decimal expansion of places
and the question of course will be can
you do that
and not upset the other precision
measurements
of the standard model but i don't think
there are that many
of the decision measures precision
predictions of the standard model
so my guess is without being being
totally ignorant
is that if we decided that this was a
new physics there's a lot of different
new physics it could be
could some of it be motivated by string
theory
sure because you can get almost anything
you want and that reminds me of uh
what nathan cyberg once said he said
most string theorists
are very arrogant if there's something
beyond string theory
we will call it string theory now he's a
well-known
uh proponent of string theory he's not
some enemy eric how do you react to
these claims that
you know kind of uh in in hindsight they
can be made compatible with almost
anything
well um that one i think i called that
your attention at some point uh so that
even if you are an anti-string theorist
you are therefore a string theorist
because string theory is whatever
uh you know its heads i win tells you
lose now of course it's not
really that way um
but it is too much that way uh with
respect to the g minus two anomaly
um i think lee said it well
and i just want to emphasize with one
point which is it's not so much that
you're inbound
invalidating the standard model
uh if this turns out to be durable
but you're if you took the standard
model to be
complete you would be invalidating
that assertion of completeness because
one way that this can happen
is that there's simply some processes
that we don't know about yet
and if you imagine that in order to get
the right answers through precision
measurement you have to sum over all
possible processes which is
sort of goes under this uh feynman
moniker of sum over histories or
path integral um
an anomaly can detect the fact that
there are channels that you know nothing
about
without telling you what those channels
are my guess is that what will happen if
this turns out to be durable
is that you'll have a change in the
inhibition
structure of the professional research
community the first things you'll start
to see
will be the absolute minimal alterations
that don't really have
much in the way of intellectual heft
so people will introduce for example uh
sterile neutrinos or they'll introduce
as
a z prime particle they'll try to do the
absolute
minimal to add to what we already know
and there will be very little reason
except that it it sort of
is kind of a race to say something that
isn't dead on arrival
then you'll burn through that period in
all likelihood and you'll get to the
point where people are actually
proposing
bold new frameworks and i think in part
that goes back to
your question brian about what
why is there a flurry of activity in
so-called theories of everything and i
think it has to do with the fact
that the way things have worked up until
very recently
is that the quantum field theory
community that sort of became the string
theory community
really was very aggressive about
shutting down alternate
approaches and then
pushing for this one approach by
seemingly relaxing some of the standards
that it is asked to satisfy while
demanding that everyone else and their
mother
satisfy the highest levels of
you know agreement between theory and
experiment while making excuses
so i think we're in a very interesting
situation
and i think what we're talking about is
a race
to find something new in experiment that
gives people
the right to be bold before we lose the
coherence of the theoretical physics
community from about 50 years
of frustration yeah i was talking lee
earlier
on the 15th anniversary of the trouble
with physics
and echoing a statement that he makes in
that book which you know check my math
eric you're a mathematician as you
frequently remind me not a physicist
that that book makes statements about
the lack of progress in the preceding 25
years
so 25 plus 15 that's 40. so that means
40
40 years of stagnation relatively
speaking in fundamental physics not in
other in particle physics etc and i
think our mutual friend
of all three of us did fundamental
physics theory-led fundamentals
theory-led
fundamental particle physics i mean
there's fundamental condensed matter
physic
et cetera that we could argue that there
has been substantial progress
but but anyway our colleague sabine
haasenfelder and friend of the show
has argued as well that you know beauty
or
aesthetically pleasing should not appear
on the rubric
in other words we should not have on the
rubric oh that your theory is
aesthetically pleasing
and then you know uh frequent guest on
the show frank wilcheck
and i know he's been on the portal as
well has said
you know actually beauty worked out
pretty well for me uh
and symmetry etc so it seems to me that
we still have this debate despite lee's
apocalype book of 2006
the trouble with physics and despite
sabina's shots across the bow
we still have graham formella who's
coming on the show uh in the next month
uh arguing that no this is the way
physics has always been we we look for
guiding principles nature
is complex variegated and beautiful and
so why not be led by those principles
in other words not only do we not have
progress maybe we can't agree on the
rubric to begin with let alone
grade the students by their lack of
progress or their progress towards some
suspected goal
may i eric you want to go ahead and um
okay let's compare this with the case
where science seems to be working
when the ligo and virgo saw
the collisions of binary neutron stars
or neutron star
black holes in the gravitational wave
data
and one of the first things that they
announced that they could measure
is the speed of gravitational waves
and that came to within measurable error
within the speed of light
and this was clean we can say it
cleanly everybody can understand what it
means
and there were a lot of theories it
turned out that people have been
developing modified gravity theories
modified
versions of general relativity that
doesn't predict this
general relativity it happens does
predict it
and so this is a clean measurement with
a clean implication
and it leads to a question and
the question i this is a there's a
friend of mine who came
and said so can you guys explain this
can you can we understand
why the speed of light and the speed of
gravitational waves are the same
and i don't think we can so it raises a
question
but that's a case of science working
it's not a question about jiggling
the ninth decimal place of something it
cleanly means something and the
measurement is pretty clean
oh well that also sorry eric i just want
to take one uh
make one comment myself which is that i
actually made that comment to michio
kaku i said not only has the speed of
light been confirmed
but also the dimensionality of space
time i said the dimensionality of space
time was limited by
um uh by oh god i'm blanking on this
name at uh chicago but but uh david
spurgle our friend and colleague a fan
of the show friend of the show
and um professor at chicago my fans on
the show will
uh suggest his name anyway the
dimensionality of space time via the
inverse
what mike turner no it wasn't mike
turner was a younger physicist
dan it's another dan or dave um i'll
look it up and i'll get it
up again but anyway that this comment uh
this this result was that the
deviation from inverse square law which
limits the number of spatial dimensions
is microscopic in other words we have no
reason to think
the of at large extra spatial dimensions
and this was met by a thud
from people like cameron vapha and
others so i mean
at what level do we go guys do we start
applying
some bayesian inference that there's
there's evidence that we should start to
say look
this should start to count against
different theories and it could be
against
e8 it could be against geometric unity
it could be
but it seems like string theory by
virtue of its prominence by the
attention give it to it invested in it
by the field
it has sort of a higher burden of proof
and i
i don't see it passing as many tests but
maybe i'm maybe i'm being too harsh on
it
what do you guys think eric why don't
you take that well you know my concern
is is that
we keep talking through proxies like i i
think that sabine is very correct
about her stance so far as using
beauty as an excuse but she's not
correct
about using beauty as a super selection
tool
to uh think about the intellectual rigor
of um interlocking frameworks which was
sort of derock's point about beauty that
beauty is is really kind of coherence
the great danger that we're in is that
we can't talk
in the present about what's really going
on which is the political economy
of theoretical physics and it has to do
with geopolitical
struggles and the way in which physics
has been a security issue it's been an
economics issue it's a prestige issue
it's a religious issue
there are various different groups and
the real reason that things are
happening
as soon as we start abstracting away
from money
in particular people and the way in
which
jobs are doled out and all these kinds
of things
all of these
human aspects are causing us to say
wrong things about science
so i appreciate you know what lee is
saying about
you know that with ligo science is
working the way it should but
to be honest there's this sort of
meta-scientific method which is the
totality of everything that has ever
worked
which includes the scientific method but
also
includes caculi getting fever dreams
about snakes eating themselves and
discovering benzene is a ring you know
so whatever it is that actually works
is part of the meta scientific method
well lee doesn't believe in the
scientific method
no that's why i agree with that i think
lee and i have been
been sort of simpatico on this for a
long time
i think that the the problem that we're
having with string theory
is that its durability has to do with
very uncomfortable
truths some of them are scientific
having to do with
one community better understanding the
requirements of renormalizability than
any other community
but it also has to do with one community
being absolutely
blocked on target in this particularly
repetitive
perseverated argument about how this
is the theory of everything and
everything else can take a hike and i'll
be honest
listening to michio kaku i wonder what
decade i'm in
that he is running around talking about
string theory is the theory of
everything shifting the burden onto
every critic
that they have to come up with the
particular vacuum or background
out of 10 to the 500 choices
in order to test string theory that
that's not his responsibility
i i honestly think that the problem here
is somebody needs
to fund a multi-day symposium
with all of the contenders for ways
forward to go at it
and then actually film it and see what
it looks like rather than
just have these people constantly sort
of brushing off all of these claimants
and string theory will soldier on
i think what we've learned and i'll
close with this is something
kind of horrific which is a lot of the
string theorists
wish to die
being on the horse that is the best
failed horse
rather than trying to turn the field
over to other people who might succeed
doing something else
and so if you want on your tombstone uh
i was a proponent of the best failed
theory of everything that we ever came
up with
um and i killed the field in order to to
to go out in this particular fashion i
think that would be very highly accurate
almost everyone we see who's a die-hard
string theorist
comes from a very particular cohort it
was in some sense a fad
that lasted way too long was far too
aggressive
and was able to simply badger people to
give up on whatever it was they were
doing and i think
it needs to be stopped well the steel
man string theory since
michio is not here uh not for lack of
trying although i didn't
invite him today but i'm certainly happy
to have him on with with you two and
others and and and he is has been
extremely gracious and in recording my
podcast twice
uh but uh but i'll steal man so i said
to him i said
um as lee and i just talked about on a
podcast will come out probably in the
next month or so
i said uh you know listen michio uh you
know there's a problem with string
theory you say in your book
uh you tell me the the vacuum equation
uh of state
out of the 10 to the 500 vacuum and and
you'll tell me what the uh what the
anomalies are and so forth and what the
you know one loop
corrections to the feminine diagrams are
and and he said well
how many equations are there in uh how
many solutions of newton's equations are
there
i said infinite number how many uh
equations are how many solutions of of
the maxwell's equations are there
infinite number i said and he said well
um and i said well but that's you know
that's really not fair
you're not in in physics i can observe
things and i can
determine the boundary conditions i can
specify initial conditions
and then the problem is uniquely
determined it's not like the vacuum has
to be determined from
we have to first select the universe and
i said that's a huge lacuna
in in string theory from my perspective
and i said it's one that say loop
quantum gravity doesn't have and he said
loop quantum gravity is a joke it
doesn't have
fermions in it it and how can you even
consider it as a candidate
for a quantum theory of gravity it
contains no fermions
and i said but i said okay well uh you
know
i'll have to let that lie fallow until i
talk to my friend lee smallin
and carlo revelli etc but um but i said
there are theories like geometric unity
has
has fermions in it and and uh and and
really there wer
there wasn't really much of a retort to
that but
the comment that i that i'm really
trying to make is that um
you know it shouldn't be on the burden
really shouldn't be on
string theorist i guess is his
perspective string theory is anomaly
free
it has uh this remarkable uh ability to
uh you know this anomaly cancellation it
has it has
um uh it's self-consistent it has
made uh you know kind of predictions as
cameron vapha said on my show
okay they're not super constraining as
regards say the mass of the electron
being greater than the planck mass and
less than
the proton mass as as he said it i can't
remember the exact
specification but he said that was a
unique prediction that was unconstrained
until string theory made that prediction
so there are predictions they're not you
know they're not particularly impressive
by you know by
particle physics standards so what do
you say that that um
these other i mean yeah okay go ahead
i'm just tired we don't have to be
talking about michio kaku
with apologies and due respect to you
eric we have to talk about because eric
has been
underheard and under
represented and under attention
otherwise we should be talking to
sabrina paternick
do you know who she is no she's 27
and she doesn't worry about what string
theory was
and what the quantum gravity was
she has a new direction and you ought to
get her on
yeah i love this
in belgium who is also somebody who
is 27 or 28
and has a new direction for fundamental
physics
and there are lots more get these people
on
[Music]
um
and if you have me on have me on because
of what i'm doing now
yeah because 30 something years ago
i helped invent group quantum gravity
which
has some successes and some failures but
he's
truly by itself not the not the
he doesn't have the ring of truth right
so
and so but there is excitement and
look up look up right now serena
gonzalez
yeah i'm looking her up yep so can i
just
say something about what i just heard if
i heard correctly
you heard lee smullen say i and a bunch
of other people
founded this field loop quantum gravity
and by itself
it doesn't have the ring of truth
something like yeah i've been saying
that for years
okay but let me just make a point
how extraordinary is it that lee can do
that
and nobody says okay well then we have
to throw it into the trash can
no we keep it around we keep it on a
shelf we know what we know about it
we keep looking at it from time to time
and what he said is by itself it doesn't
carry the day
now that is one of the best arguments
for loop quantum gravity that i've ever
heard
and the argument is loop quantum gravity
does not force you to join
a cult it allows you to continue to be a
scientist it allows you to continue to
listen to other people
and by the way i feel the same way about
gu my desire
is never to shut up any rival
i don't want string theory shut up i
want
string theorists to stop being so
aggressive and trying to shut down
everything else and you know they have a
weird point
they have a point that a lot of the
other claimants to to
the um you know potential
uh next leap
don't understand some of the issues that
they understand best particularly around
renormalizability
okay fine very well but
tough luck at some level at the moment
we've been so long without success
allowing all sorts of diseased partial
ideas
um things that you know new spins that
are incomplete
all of these things should be welcome in
a field that's in danger of not being
able to renew itself
and i just think that what we heard was
what lee
said is the way scientists
are supposed to sound it's not the fact
you know somebody could easily say
so and so is a string theorist he or she
has spent their whole life it's
understandable that of course they're
not going to change when they're older
well lee is older he's spent his entire
life in research
and he's still a scientist right and i
think it's just
we have to recognize something very
weird happened
in string theory in particular it
doesn't look like any other subfield
of fundamental part so i want to talk
about from my perspective
you know i'm just a humble
experimentalist so i've got sabrina's
picture up
i think it's her uh and by the way she's
she's made in her phd which was at
harvard
an actual tradition
wow and uh she's uh mentored by freeman
dyson who's a guest on the show
way back when i first started the into
the impossible podcast which reminds me
please do subscribe
i've had nine nobel laureates eric
weinstein several times lisa mullen
several times stephan alexander
sabina hassenfelder and many many other
great guests and more coming up
on i will you'll be blown away
i absolutely will and you know in
cosmology things are also challenging
right because we have
we have a paradigm that is dominated by
a single monopolistic
entity namely inflation uh which has
stunning successes but also
maybe uh the analogy is that it uh can't
account for its own initial conditions
any better than string theory can
account for its initial conditions
and i think you know physicists struggle
with this and
conflate the problem of cosmology with
cosmogeny
you know the theory of cosmic origins
and it's inevitable that things like
this will come up but lee i've made this
point to eric you know that um
theories are cheap and they flourish
like software and and
and compared to hardware it's much
harder you know how many
how many software companies were started
at uh
outside of a perimeter you know or
starting blackberry
uh you know how many software companies
were started in the in the greater
toronto area or the california area
compared to hardware companies they're
very few in california
uh that are that are hardware compared
to software which is great and so it's
easier
in some sense to create wonderful hard
software than hardware and
kind of experiments are like that and
whenever i hear i've got this great new
theory of everything
and my colleagues say well we just need
to build a bigger collider to test it i
say well god gave
you these two giant 30 mah solar mass
stars to collide together
and black holes to collide together
isn't that good enough you know at what
level
do we need to uh to test the
fundamentals of physics by always
promising it's just beyond the far
horizon
and i think physicist we're not doing
ourselves a great
service as eric points out we kind of
have the best score ever written and
we're the best you know we're the worst
performers of that score
but something to that effect eric you
can you can quote yourself
slightly better than i can you're the
bob dylans of the sciences
okay i'm not 100 sure what that means
but yeah go ahead lee
um i don't think theory is cheap and as
somebody who has actually
tried to make new theories
it's bloody hard and eric is another
person who has tried
over a lifetime to make a new theory and
it is you'll agree with me it's really
hard to get it right
oh yeah oh certainly it is bad theories
are cheap
bad theories yes exactly right whereas
no one will build you know a 37
kilometer
you know accelerator ring that's bad you
know and and also i think that
all experiments are beautiful lee i
think you know whereas you know
sabine might have a point about theories
being you know too
lost in beauty and lost in math but but
all experiments are beautiful in their
own right even the ones that are ugly in
other words
we look for symmetry we look for
jackknives that fail we look for
departures that don't make sense and
that's part of our stock and trade as
as good experimentalists to assay what
is nature trying to tell us and i look
back to
someone like uh like isaac newton he
didn't need
uh you know a um a spectrometer you know
etc to you know
with with with an extra x-ray
diffraction you know spectrometer to
understand
waves and and so forth in the wave
nature of light he had a prism
and he had a darkened room and he had
the sun and he understood color
synthesis
and and so forth and and i'm wondering
are there theories
whose low energy limit we can test very
easily with low-cost experiments and
maybe with data
that you and stefan and jerome and other
people are looking at with gen with
machine learning
are there are other you know data sets
out there
that may contain low energy physics that
can already be tested without always
looking to this bigger better collider
down the street or down the horizon
yes and i'll tell you what you have to
think about what you have to think about
is when you say the gravitational field
goes to flat space time
when you go to infinity there's actually
an infinite number of flat space times
it could be going to and there is
which are connected of course by
different morphisms
and it could be going to a different
flat space time
in that direction in that direction and
in that direction
and what these young people have been
inventing is new observables
that come from giving a kind of
non-integrability of what you mean by
flat space time
when you go out in that direction in
that direction
when they produce and eric you
your geometer i think if you look at
these you'll understand what's going on
and they produce predictions for ligo
and and virgo and the new
lisa and so forth and that's
the very rare thing of theorists
thinking hard about their theories
and coming up with new things for for
cosmologists to look
you know i think that the the last
really
impressive tabletop sort of surprise
might have been and lee can correct me
you might know the history
quite a bit better than i do the the
iron off bone
uh effect in the 1950s
was sort of a an opportunity to say we
don't need
a bigger collider we just need to
actually believe in something that makes
almost no sense intuitively
and then go look for it and find out
that it's true and you know a little bit
more complex
than that was was the uh weak force
asymmetry experiment
with the cobalt 60. and i
worry in some sense that
we are both attached to that kind of
um simplicity in terms of a relationship
between theory and experiment
but it's not necessarily applicable by
the way the g minus 2
is in some sense a precision experiment
rather than a
super high energy experiment coming off
of the ring that was at brookhaven and
moved to fermilab so i do think that
precision is one way to get around
higher energy requirements but it's a
trade-off between precision and energy
and then i also think i'll be blunt
about it
that um i don't think i understood the
relationship between
theory and experiment in a human context
i thought of it as a scientific thing
absent humans
i think that in large measure one of the
reasons that experiment really matters
is that a very small number of humans
can remain
disciplined and honest over long periods
of time when
nothing much is happening an experiment
is this very rude shock you don't
find many bullshitters in the free solo
community
um in climbing because if you bulge it
against a granite wall
you know you're kidding yourself uh so i
do think that in large measure
experiment is sort of like the tide
going out you can see who's wearing swim
trunks when you don't have a lot of
great experiments
people can tell a lot of stories and i
think that that's just something
very difficult for us to actually
recognize
and when i look at the you know history
of physics often it's pointed out that
you know a good a good experiment
should be a decisive experiment you know
there's some word for that in latin
um and they point to you know the
eddington experiment of
starlight bending by the sun you know
and scientists debate whether or not
that was actually technically feasible
even
even to this day but but nevertheless it
was of course verified in the 60s with
radar astronomy
but um there's a virtue in keeping even
wrong theories
alive as karl popper said and lee i'd
like to talk to you about this as we
didn't have a chance in our solo episode
but i believe that as the soft sciences
have
physics envy and as freud used to speak
about
a certain kind of envy um i believe
physicists have math
envy in that mathematicians like our
friend eric
have an ability to uh to bound what is
knowable
and what is not consistent via the
girdle incompleteness theorem
but there is no such thing for physics
and therefore we
cobble together we construe this
amalgam of popper and cune
and the scientific method and we say
that this is what science is and it's
predicated on falsifiability
but even popper in his writings helga
crag and others point this out
he said there's a virtue in keeping even
unknown wrong theory
around um it it is has a certain assay
value in its own right what do you think
about this uh this
this uh infatuation with falsifiability
is it sacrosanct in in physics
um so first of all you left out fault
fire almonds who i think is the
substance the antidote to popper
and jacob um
i think i think we do
the best we can and for me
and i appreciate very much what eric was
saying
um these are communities and my
understanding of how science works is as
a community
you don't get to be a scientist all by
yourself
there is a community that you enter and
you enter it
by basically establishing that you can
make a case
for an argument that
is worth your colleagues paying
attention to
and there's an ethics and there's an
ethics
of being honest taking seriously
other people's claims and other people's
evidence
and where did everybody go you're there
just spotlighting you um so
i think that good science is
done by people who care about finding
out about nature
and who have an ethics which
allows other people with the same
training with similar training
to evaluate their claims as painful as
that
sometimes is and i think you become a
scientist
by recognizing the paradox that's
involved in being part of a community
and the paradox
for me is you have to push your own
ideas and discoveries no one else will
and so you've got to be confident
sometimes arrogant and at the same time
you have to be
deeply respectful of the community
of other scientists because it's them
who are going to ultimately judge
whether your work is a value and i think
being able to live on that edge
is not easy speaking personally and
it's what it is to me what and i think
i'm reinforcing what i've said
it doesn't work unless the people
have the commitment to
the truth at whatever it costs and i
know that's
that sounds naive and silly and
that's what i think it doesn't mean
eric you want to respond yeah so
it's an interesting point you see that
there are two separate ways that we
mathematicians and physicists are
divided by what they can
check against mathematics has internal
consistency
as its coin of the realm
and so if you can make an argument that
your colleagues believe is internally
consistent and that
can defeat all challengers uh
we say that you have proven something
and you can get into a very detailed
argument about what constitutes proof
because it's not always clear
in the case of physics you have this
very different way of
checking your answers uh effectively you
check them against nature
to the best of your experimental friends
ability to conduct something
now in an overlap region you might have
something like
let's say the feynman path integral
which can sort of be checked
uh in terms of let's say perturbation
series
uh the first few terms of it can be
checked
[Music]
for once it's not my baby for once it's
not one of my babies
go ahead and eric i'll take it off there
we go
he has become a fidei of pop off ghost
um what what you what you're able to do
is to ask um
did nature agree with the first few
terms of a perturbation series oh she
did the high order role that's that's
fantastic
um but that's very different because you
don't have that opportunity
often in mathematics to check it against
something external
so therefore you have this this funny
situation with with feynman
where it's not proven mathematics you
could say that math
has physics envy that we wish we knew
what nonsensical
expressions we could write down that
would be meaningful
and the last thing about this
which is probably the most important
thing
is why i'm so terrified
by the scientific method people don't
understand this at all
it's naive scientific method that we
should be
fearful of and and dirac makes this
point perfectly
his point if properly understood is that
you may have a
theory and an instance of the theory
so you have a particular concrete
version of the equation that embodies an
idea
let's say and you may have no agreement
with experiment
because the instance of the theory was
not the right instance
but the theory had multiple
instantiations
and another one can be right and so this
idea of
you know i there's a feynman and a
video clip from i think cornell where he
says
if your theory doesn't agree with
experiment it's wrong it's wrong
and it's it's like no it's really
unhelpful
yes in a technical sense your
instantiated theory
is wrong if the experimentalist did his
or her work blah blah blah
but it doesn't mean your theory is wrong
it means the instantiation
of your theory is wrong and this
issue of wanting to hold up
scientific figures holding very
simplistic but therefore powerful points
of view another one is
if you can't explain it to your
grandmother you don't understand it
right and then yeah and they'll put
feynman's name or something on that and
then he'll say if i could explain it to
you it wouldn't be worth a nobel prize
right so at some level part of the
problem
here is that everyone right now is so
badly behaved because mom and dad have
been gone for like 50 years
and your useless older brother has been
you know holding a rave in the house
for for almost as you know for 40 of
those 50 years
everybody is behaving terribly in my
opinion almost
and as a result we're having ward about
what is science what isn't science
because we're not doing science and if
we were doing science and we were
evaluating each other's theories and
proposing experiments and asking why are
we in the situation
we were holding conferences you know
with terrifying title like wither
theoretical physics
um that would be indicative of the of
the sort of pre-apocalyptic state
that this field is in we're not doing
that and so i
i fear that in part we're spending our
last gasp of energy pretending
that everything is going normally and
not recognizing that this is an absolute
emergency you need to have
winds in a field in order for the field
to know how to work
if if at some level you look at orcas or
tigers
they teach their children how to hunt
right
and if you don't actually have the
ability to hunt you starve
and this field has lost the ability to
hunt
i want to ask a question to both you
guys uh and that
is whether we could come up if we have
the temerity to come up with a
rubric ourselves i mean what stops us
from coming up with the scorecard and
eric and i have talked about this
offline on one of the many
10 000 steps eric has taken to not only
get a six-pack but a 12-pack
which uh you know would invalidate any
jabs i would give him
he's so studly it's really frustrating
anyway
um but i want to ask uh let's let's
let's run this by lee
what would you expect from a theory of
everything so
uh pace kaku for a minute but um
i would i would want to know does it
include uh the three generations of
fermions
eric would surely ask about uh the
origin of chirality
um i would want to ask uh about
anti-matter
i want to ask about does it incorporate
a and the origin of the universe
itself um eric would want to
ask about where does the ckm matrix come
from
um eric can you think of others lee can
you think of others would you talk about
space time emerging
what would you add to a requirement
you're grading the three of us
uh admittedly somewhat biased observers
we're grading
a theory of everything comes across our
desk how do we grade it what do you
include in the scorecard
i don't want to do that all right i
think it's
it's it's a unique occurrence
um we don't need some formal thing like
that to
agree at least i don't that we're in
trouble that
there's an issue to be understood and i
don't think
that kind of thing
with respect at least i don't
i don't want to play that way i i
think that when when we have something
which answers a substantial number of
the open questions in a way that's
convincing
and clearly the best explanation on the
table to quote david deutsch
um we'll know it and whether and i
expect to get surprised
so maybe that's the only thing
sorry eric what i i totally disagree
with
my friend lee here okay yeah
you have a certain number of
very stylized features
of the world and you want some
answer to all of them
including that's not actually a problem
right so
you want for example some
let me take a simple one uh around 1984
we went from talking about unified
theories
to talking very specifically about
quantizing gravity
it was a strange replacement where
it was not even clear that you want to
quantize gravity you certainly want to
make gravity
compatible with quantum theory but the
idea that you want to treat
gravity as another field and quantize it
and that you know this and everybody who
doesn't know this is wrong and they
don't get it
is insane okay but
so you'd want to pull back and you'd say
okay i want to know how does your theory
attempt to harmonize
the coexistence between gravity and
quantum theory
and that's that's there's nothing wrong
with that question and i think what
leaves fear about is that somebody puts
up the wrong set of questions that
misguide the field but if you pull back
on all of these
you could say why do we think that we
see three generations
why does nature appear to be flavor
chiral
why this assortment of internal quantum
numbers
why the number of 16 particles in the
generation where did the ckm matrix come
from
why why does the ig sector
which looks geometric at one level not
look
familiar from the point of view of
differential geometry where every other
sector looks exactly like
top drawer differential geometry to a
mathematician
so you can list and we used to list
a large number of stylized problems
that you could then say any theory i
this theory declines to answer this this
quest this theory reframes this question
this theory
gives an answer etcetera etcetera
etcetera
i remember for example that in the early
days of string theory i was told with
certainty
that the reason there were three
generations of of chiral fermions
was that there was a six-dimensional
manifold called the kalabi-yao
at every point in space and time and
then
its topology carried an index in
in the index of elliptic operator theory
that determined the number of
generations to be three
no that's a very same thing pardon me
i was told the same thing okay that's
like a very
specific claim about why there are three
generations
and i think that that should be listed
on a matrix and if it's
changed or while we have 27 different
ways of generating three generations or
we'll tell you once you tell us more
about the universe
whatever it is put it down and i think
what lee is
fearful of is we don't want certain
people
writing down this list so that their
theory
specifically you know it shows off
whatever their theory does well i think
i heard michio say
it should agree with general relativity
it should agree with the standard model
and something very specific about like i
don't know the one loop level
uh or some some calculation of
finiteness
uh for gravity to to one loop or who
knows what
uh and then throwing in something about
anomaly free
now what you want is you want to say
sure
you should put that anomaly free you
should put down unitary
you should put down um you know maybe
you want positive energy whatever it is
but what you should then do
is that you should pull back and ask
if we think of these things as technical
debt
you may start a project not knowing how
you're going to solve something in
particular
um just get each theory to take on its
technical debt without
pretending that if you can actually find
something that somebody can't
answer to your satisfaction then they're
out that thing is a thing
string and and friends of string theory
specialty
it's just trying to clear the deck out
of other people working on different
approaches
and those people are allowed to take on
the same kind of technical debt
that string theory is and given how many
people have worked on strength theory i
think what i'm trying to say is
we don't have a problem with string
theory we have a problem with the
political economy of string
theorists it is not the only absolutist
religion in academia
yeah if you go into economics there's
something literally called economic
imperialism
where they celebrate the destruction of
other fields at the hands of economics
right the absolutist triumphalist
strain of american academics is the
problem
and you find it in the neo-darwinian
synthesis you find it
in neoclassical economics and you find
it in string theory
and the key thing is the field needs to
fight back
against the totality totalizing
absolutist
impulse of the triumphalists
i mean can that comment extreme danger i
mean for example i
i tweeted out last month when the g
minus two
anomaly was announced that um was there
i just asked an innocent question i said
was there any concern
due to the fact that the storage ring
for these muons was
an identical was the identical unit used
to store the muons at brookhaven
uh that came up with a 3.8 sigma
detection 22 years ago or was first
built 22 years ago
brookhaven you know didn't appreciate my
subtweeting and
i didn't get any reply from that um
there's also the that's been pointed out
that uh the higgs particle has only been
really discovered or inferred to exist
from a single decay channel
um and that uh and that was a five sigma
result
um which is which is you know obviously
very powerful and
and definitive in in physics circles but
the the fact that they
the single channel uh you know photon
photon channel
for example um we have um a plethora of
of black hole and neutron star mergers
that have occurred they all seem to have
the same you know mass range and
and spin orientation um now that could
just be
you know some some sensitivity effect or
or something
uh that uh is peculiar to the instrument
um but but you know i can ask these
questions as an outsider maybe it's
annoying uh
at some level but uh but you know i'm
not i'm not really
in in the game and maybe i'm just doing
it uh to satisfy some
some um you know speculation but
is there not a great greater risk to do
that you know when you're
a young you know a postdoc searching for
a job when
when you're yeah go ahead
it's our job to fight for the young
which is one of the things that i'm very
upset about with the older generations
this should not be life and death
somebody should be figuring out at the
beginning
are you good enough to be doing research
in these fields if you
are it's very important to recognize
that you're prohibited from
taking part in the in the economy there
are rules on intellectual property but
not commercializing fundamental
discoveries and things like that
we should be fighting like hell to
ensure that the young have enough to eat
and that they don't have to follow the
elderly
in order to survive and i just i want to
make
very clear that um
there's no way of solving this with
the hunger games if we're going to run a
if we're going to run the hunger games
we should just kiss the field goodbye
and stop pretending to do physics so lee
speaking of natural selection darwinian
competition i have a question from a
listener do you see
any way for the cosmological natural
selection principle
to counter the prime mover the necessity
of a prime mover
sure what's the problem with a necessity
well i guess would you does the
cosmological natural selection
that you advocate in the life of the
cosmos does that
does that uh have any bearing on the
necessity of a of a creator
no no
if you care about that kind of question
you can just push it back
i mean if cosmological natural selection
is right
the big bang is not the first moment of
time
and it's something that happened in a
prior
causally prior universe and there were
other
causally prior universes because it has
to have been going on
for some time and if that
bothers you then you just keep going
back and at some point
if you're the sort of person who wants
to know was there
something that god started then you can
ask your question there
i don't i'm a scientist i don't think
answering that question is part of my
job description
i have had on uh intelligent designers
on the show i don't shy away from that
stephen meyer who's a
philosopher of science a cambridge uh
university phd i had him on the show he
has a new book called the
return of the god hypothesis in which he
argues
against the notion that that structure
that information
comes from the uh from natural processes
but if the universe pre-existed the big
bang it doesn't sound necessarily to be
in conflict
with that necessarily although i don't
assume that you're an intelligent design
proponent i don't think i've ever talked
to eric about this eric
when stephen meyer or other proponents
of intelligent design say the following
they say
information can always be traced back to
a creator of that information how do you
react to that
well first of all you're you're opening
up
let's just be very clear what you're
opening up the two words intelligent
and design when placed proximate to each
other
constitutes a sort of rotating buzz
saw that you can push someone into what
do you think about intelligent design
in the normal world you say oh i don't
know if there's anything to it maybe
there's something to it i don't know
but if you say that in science it's like
what do you mean you don't know that
it's quackery and pseudoscience and
so you can't casually ask me about it
if you're actually asking about
intelligent design i'll say something
terrifying yeah the religious
community of scientists who study
intelligent design
um are split between those who are
willing to play by the rules of science
and those who are so
desperate to get to the answer that uh
it all comes from jesus
or the equivalent that they're willing
to cut any corners to to make sure that
the bible is validated and they're not
really scientists
they're quests okay now the thing we
don't appreciate
is how important the religious
scientists are
because of the hunger games because
people who are religiously motivated
will take on issues that will
sort of be tantamount to career
destruction if they feel that the
science is wrong
and i think you can make an excellent
argument that the field
of evolution technically the theory of
selection
tried to close the door on
selection in certain ways to say we have
a theory
it got finalized maybe sometime in the
early 70s more or less
and then use
the claim that no one who's ever
published in intelligent design has ever
passed peer review
so it's a very efficient way of getting
god
out of the sciences to say that
effectively
that the neo-darwinian hypothesis
is settled and that random mutation is
the major
engine of selection and it's great
that we have religious scientists who
are willing to to
question that at great cost to
themselves
the only difference is do they agree to
play by the rules of science
in their motivated search to find a
problem with the science or do they
believe that they are entitled to play
by different rules because they
they have the truth and they can feel it
in their bosom
and so i'm pretty uh thankful
that religiously motivated true
scientists exist
in part because of the economics they
are maybe
the last people who will turn out the
light if we continue to destroy
ourselves through
starving the young for security and any
kind of feeling that they can survive
to live another day if they follow their
own ideas
okay may i just say something simple of
course
well uh eric i i appreciate that but
that's that's
too sophisticated for me um
there are mysteries in the world
consciousness
the meaning of life of the meaning of
the universe
the beginning of the origin of the
universe
um i think that
we who have a
what you what some people would call a
scientific world view
which is not all scientists but a
worldview
in which there is not a spirit or a god
which does things which set the universe
into motion
so we're investigating a different kind
of hypothesis
and i think we should be upfront
that the religious dias hypothesis
fulfills some things for many people
explains to them something about the
meaning of life and what's important
about life
when we say when i'm speaking for myself
we're not interested in that hypothesis
we fail to make up
that is we leave a gap in the emotional
spiritual lives of many people that we
don't address by just simply saying for
example with steve weinberg
that the more we understand about the
university more pointless it seems to be
and i think that
we who are not deits
have a responsibility to explain
to our fellow human beings
what we believe and what we have in mind
for addressing those issues that
religious that religions
did address or do address
and if we don't at least acknowledge
that
we lose credibility because that's i
think that's
really the situation
now um
there's been a long
there are so i think it's important
that people i like very much the word of
good faith
people of good faith who have different
views about spiritual religious problems
and science in relation to
communicate with each other those people
who
have integrity and recognize
the issues i think it's interesting and
important for us
to communicate in that domain and not
pretend that it doesn't exist and not
pretend
that the people on the other side are
insufficient or dumb or something
and i personally met enough
rabbis and roman catholic priests and
episcopal
priests of various kinds who had
profoundly interesting things to discuss
and they didn't challenge science in
silly stupid ways
and they didn't um and i
accepted their authority and their
domain not over me
but what what their studies meant
so i am not with richard dawkins i don't
think that we should sustain
contact with religious people especially
thoughtful accomplished intelligent
religious people
and i think it's very important for the
future of our civilization
now we myself
i don't know that i've ever said this
publicly before
i i was raised i'm jewish
but i was raised by parents who followed
a certain practice called the guru chief
work
and i'm certainly not part of them now
but my religious spiritual background
is very different than most people
and occasionally that comes out in
things i say
but that's so that's i don't want to
hijack your program what was that what
was that sub
was that the bird what was that again
he was a he was a russian armenian
who traveled in the east and studied
eastern practices
and made a version of them
that was stripped of the historical
and storytelling attributes for training
to people in the west
interesting yeah i had on um well michio
obviously and he concludes his book the
god equation with this
word the five words that stephen hawking
concluded a brief history of time with
which is
if we get a theory of everything then we
could know the mind of god
and and in his book he talks about his
own upbringing
born to buddhist parents but raised uh
presbyterian
and then believing in what is he called
einstein's god
which is really spinoza's god it gets
very complicated
but i'm speaking as an as a jewish
person who was an altar boy in the
catholic church so
i really can't you know speak about
complexities when it comes to religion
but i do want to say that i think
stephen hawking was a very deeply
religious person
it's just that he didn't he wasn't
practicing and in the hebrew language
the word
israel means to wrestle or struggle with
god
and hawking constantly struggles with
god and all of his writing
all of his books he's always making
arguments against god and the necessity
of god
via m theory in the grand design via
um the hawking hardell no boundary
theory and i
actually i've never heard you speak
about the no boundary theory
in a brief history he talks about it as
if it's sort of accepted physics
was that influential at all in your
career i mean do physicists use the
hawking heartless theory at any
at to any extent nowadays in cosmology
i'm going to really get in trouble
that's why i turned down a job offer
from stephen
no way oh wait you can't you can't leave
that hanging that's too big
i'm hanging because i want to i want to
end what i have to say
with a quote by saint clair cement who i
think i mentioned
is a great resilient sculptor who
and once i was i was
i was being interviewed by the bbc
and i was really frustrated and felt i
hadn't gotten my point across
and then i went to a party and i ran
into sinclair and i expressed that
and he said look i don't understand what
your trouble is
your book this is the life of the cosmos
is has a very simple message and i said
okay sinclair what's the message of that
book
it says message of the book is that the
universe
is so splendorous and complex
and beautiful that even the absence of
god would be guided enough
that's right lee wiesel said a person
can be
angry at god could be happy with god but
not without god
eric any final words from you before we
wrap up this delightful stream and
and pachin oh michio kaku is calling no
i'm just kidding he's not calling but
that would be fun wouldn't it
any words from you eric yeah sure i mean
i i think that we make a huge mistake
we're in the god business that's why
people
care about theoretical physics and
what's fascinating here of course
is that you know this stuff is written
in the language of differential geometry
and quantum field theory
and we don't have people who want to
read
i don't know syriac or you know ancient
hebrew or
whatever it is that you know the ruins
uh
are are written in now what i find
amazing is is that we have these
programs
and i always hope that we're gonna end
up talking about like the nuts and bolts
of what we've become
to understand about the universe and
instead we sort of talk about
what we've come to understand about the
universe
we've turned physics very much i think
narcissistically into a story about us
and it may be that humans can't stop
talking about god and they can't stop
talking about themselves because mostly
these things are divorced from both
contexts
but i think when you're actually in a
situation in which
you're you're talking about well what is
this place
what is creation what is the strange
world in which we find ourselves
i think it doesn't do us any service
to back out of the fact that we're
trying to
change the nature of the gaps in which
gods of the gaps have traditionally
lived and i think that that's
you don't have to call it god you can
simply say i want to have a richer
understanding of the place and the
context in which i live in it and the
stuff of which i am
stuff of which i'm comprised and so
what we don't want is we don't want
pseudoscience
what we don't want is we don't want
um sort of storytelling and madness
given how much is on the line and you
know i say this this this
thing i said in passing to joe rogan
which is
we after the events of 1952 and 53 we
are now
god's but for the wisdom i think that we
have to recognize
that when you can create a
fusion event on the surface of the earth
you break it you bought it we are now if
we don't actually
take on the responsibilities of who we
have become
in in particular due to theoretical
physics
even if you want to say it's biological
look who founded
molecular biology it was theoretical
physics again
so you have this very dangerous
situation in which we are
unlocking what life is schrodinger
famously writing what is life
mathematician physicist john von neumann
talking to us about the informational
content of life we are talking about the
informational content of black holes
we're creating
fusion on the surface of the earth we're
sending radio waves
we are also in a situation whereby our
federal government
is now going to stir things up
talking about ufos is real which is
going to have a
hugely religious component for this
they've changed
the federal government this is
interesting you haven't heard this
our defense department in the u.s oh
you're canadian it hasn't gotten here
our defense department has gotten into
a situation whereby we are supposed to
have revelations about ufo research
presented i think by the first of june
we've had former cia directors
sitting senators um
in the depend defense department saying
that ufo
footage is real and that these these are
frequent
events i've never heard anything
remotely this crazy and one of the
things the fact that i'm just going to
bring up
if you if lee smolin doesn't know
that there's been a huge sea change in
ufos
it's a cinch that whoever it is that's
running the ufo show
is not reaching out to the physics and
math communities which would be the
first two communities that you would
want involved at the high level
now the kind of is this pendant but let
me
remember hillary clinton who i once
from my amazement heard say that one
reason to vote for her for president
was that if she was president she would
make public the secrets about ufos
well what i would say about this is
there are very few
really deep mysteries um
i don't even know how to say it where we
are going with this ufo narrative
uh is going to get into religious
questions
if no matter what they turn over by this
point
and it's very important that the math
and physics communities stop avoiding
these questions to celebrate their
atheism yet again
instead what we need to do is we need to
say look
this comes out of the impulse to
understand the world just as religion
came out of the impulse to make sense
out of the chaos
and we're going to have to stop with the
overlap with the non-overlapping
magisteria because these things are
going to start to impinge on each other
and i do think what we should do is take
the religious impulse
and channel it into productive uh
rational scientific behavior you want to
know you want to be in contact and
dialogue with something larger than
yourself
the way to do it is through data
responsible theorizing and
not fearing your own uh
longing for the transcendent okay i
gotta tell a story and then
i i'm out of here okay i with great
respect for you guys
i was once on a radio show run by
canadian
broadcasting about what we should say
to the aliens when they land in toronto
and how we should congress with him
and i prepared for this by reading
homer and by reading a little book that
i found in a bookstore
called amy greets the aliens i'm not
kidding
and so when it was my turn on the radio
show
which was filmed at new york university
um i
said the most important thing and i
think
we should think about this is
hospitality
i said as we learn from the greeks when
somebody arrives from
far far away you make them a feast you
give them a bath
they're tired they're dirty they're
hungry and only on the third night
you get to ask them how this spaceship
works
or where they come from when amy and
greece the aliens have the same message
give them kool-aid before you ask them
if you can go with them
wherever they're going and i'm i'm
trying to maintain the right sense of
and i'm reacting a little bit because i
haven't heard of it
of course like so many of us we grew up
from little boys and girls
who thought about running away with the
alien
and i think we should i think that
if that's real um
we should remember homer we should
remember amy
and long before we ask them how the
spaceship works
we should ask them what they what they
come here
to tell us but speaking oh go ahead
sorry about this brian i think the most
important thing if lee's going to do
this is we need to remember the lesson
of captain cook
that when captain cook showed up in the
hawaii islands he was
treated as a god because they had a myth
about a white god descending
they treated him to the feast that li
talks
about we treated him beautifully
unfortunately that meant that when he
went to set sail
his people longed for the good old days
of going back
to the feast so when god came back a
second time
too quickly after having taken all the
best pigs or fruits or whatever they
killed them
and so i always thought that was really
interesting that it only took one
meeting to get over the whole reverence
for god thing before you get to the
point with this guy's here again
so we need to remember all of these
tales
and greatly enjoyed that's right when
people say oh i'll believe in god when i
hear you know as woody allen said the
divine sneeze that's all i want
uh speaking of aliens i'm having on andy
weir author of the martian on tomorrow
on the into the impossible podcast
followed by stephen pinker steven
strogatz and many other
luminaries coming up we have on the
great i'm hoping to have gerard
hoofed coming soon and many other
luminaries in the world of physics
mathematics philosophy
and many other things but i greatly
appreciate you two a gentleman joining
me today lee
uh your episode will be out uh we
recorded earlier this morning
eric you're always welcome on the into
the impossible podcast proprietor of the
portal please subscribe
over there and uh and lee have a
wonderful day
we'll have links to all your papers uh
that are coming up lee has three
spectacular new papers that are out
on the archive everybody enjoy and uh
see you next time on the end of the
impossible podcast with yours truly dr
brian keating
thank you thank you thank you